FIFA the organization that sounds the
most like the name of a purse dog it's
not Fifi its FIFA you may remember last
year we examined what an appalling
organization FIFA is treating countries
that host the World Cup like cash
machines practically imposing their own
rule of law generating billions of
dollars and yet somehow remaining a
non-profit now
despite being almost the dictionary
definition of corruption they've escaped
any significant prosecution for decades
but that all ended on Wednesday high
ranking officials from FIFA the sport's
governing body arrested in an overnight
raid in Switzerland the result of a
sweeping FBI investigation I don't know
what I'm more surprised by that FIFA
officials were actually arrested or that
America was behind it it took the
country that cares the least about
football to bring down the people who
have been ruining it that's that's like
finding out that Kesha arrested a group
of bankers involved in commodities fraud
while catcher
I actually did not think this was an
interest of yours well you've been
undeniably effective tenacious
prosecution came
it's not just the fact of the arrests it
was spectacular
it's how they were carried out we saw
several of those FIFA officials led from
the hotel I think it was the hotel staff
trying to protect their appearance if
not their dignity with white hotel
sheets that is perfect because hotel
sheets are very much like FIFA officials
they really should be clean but they're
actually unspeakably filthy and deep
down everybody knows that essentially
the US government has accused FIFA
officials of soliciting 150 million
dollars in bribes and kickbacks in forms
ranging from cash in a briefcase to an
expensive painting which to be fair is
unexpectedly classy corruption for
sports executives because if you wanted
to bribe Roger Goodell all you'd really
need is a cardboard box filled with old
playboys
apparently the big breakthrough came
when the IRS caught Chuck blazer a
corrupt American FIFA official and
actual Bad Santa for many years
Glazer didn't even file a tax return
which was a little suspicious
considering the lifestyle he lived his
criminal activity financed an opulent
lifestyle that included a luxury
apartment in New York's Trump Tower for
the use of his cats Wow none of us not
what aloof really means until we meet a
cat that has its own apartment in Trump
Tower he probably doesn't even lick
himself he just uses the on-site dry
cleaning
now blazer became an FBI informant and
with his help the US government managed
to produce a 164 page indictment which I
genuinely recommend that you read
because it's amazing look let me give
you just a taste for instance it alleges
that former FIFA vice president Jack
Warner tried to help buy votes with
envelopes containing $40,000 in cash and
when someone objected he said if your
pious open a church friends our business
is our business which is not just awful
it's factually incorrect because opening
a church is a fantastic way to make a
ton of money that's just a fact and
if you need any more proof that Jack
Warner could not give less of a listen
to this after he was arrested he left
jail in an ambulance claiming exhaustion
exhaustion that he then recovered from
miraculously quickly hours after he was
released from jail the former FIFA exact
owned politician was defiant as he
addressed a rally that is cocky denying
any involvement while singing every
little things gonna be alright as songs
go that's a little on the nose I guess
we're just lucky that he didn't go we've
got your money by ol Dirty Bastard which
come to think of it are three words that
describe Jack Warner perfectly but the
cherry on top of all of this was a video
Jack Warner released just today where he
suggested that this arrest was all a
conspiracy bringing hard proof in the
form of a newspaper article stating that
FIFA was trying to placate the u.s. by
giving them an extra World Cup this year
FIFA as frantically I knows 2015 2015
this year this year I am a little bit
final in the World Cup began May 27 if
the professor bad why is it the USA
wants to keep if if I woke up and let's
be fair he's right FIFA giving the u.s.
an extra world cup is comically
ridiculous it's the sort of thing you'd
usually see in an onion article which it
turns out was
clean what he was holding up and he says
something and so something about how
corrupt she fades from one of their ex
vice presidents could look at that story
and think yeah that sounds like
something they might do yeah but maybe
the most remarkable thing about all of
the charges is that they didn't touch
Sepp Blatter who's been president of
FIFA for the last 17 years now on his
watch the World Cup has left a trail of
devastation just last year Brazil spent
billions of dollars on massive new
stadiums to host the World Cup stadiums
which have met a predictable fate these
days there's very little football being
played at the world's second most
expensive Stadium in fact it mostly sits
empty
after hosting less than a handful of
matches during last year's World Cup
it's never been filled again today it
serves mainly as a parking lot for these
buses you have to give them credit
FIFA literally went into Brazil paved
paradise and put up a parking lot but
that is just a drop in the ocean of what
has happened on Blatter's watch just
look at what's gonna happen next
Saturday when the Women's World Cup
starts Blatter has previously suggested
raising the popularity of women's soccer
by saying they could for example have
tighter shorts female players are pretty
and it is rare to find a non fired boss
who will openly say I would like to make
it easier for me to masturbate to my
employees
and as you will see next week that is
pretty much the full extent of Blatter's
care for female players legs every game
will be played for the first time in
history on artificial turf many US team
members are livid it is gender equality
issue no chance with the men ever play a
World Cup on turf LaRue recently posted
pictures of skin burns she says were
caused by turf holy the last time
an athlete's legs were beaten up that
badly in advance of a major competition
it was because Tonya Harding was
unwilling to settle for silver
but no decision Blatter has overseen is
more questionable than the 2022 World
Cup being awarded to Qatar because not
only will the conditions be terrible to
play in but the number of migrant
workers that have died in Qatar
since the cup was announced has been
staggering now the numbers are difficult
to pin down but a report by the
International Trade Union Confederation
for example has estimated 1,200 deaths
so far with up to 4,000 additional
worker deaths by 2022 now even if all
those are not directly related to the
World Cup those are still natural
disaster numbers where the services
should start issuing FIFA warnings a
stadium is being planned in your area
evacuate immediately and you would think
all this might cost Sepp Blatter his job
and on Friday he was actually up for
re-election as FIFA's president and
offered a pretty terrible defense for
himself I know many people hold me
ultimately responsible for the actions
and reputation of the global football
community we or I cannot monitor
everyone all of the time that is weak
you are basically Charles Manson saying
listen I've got a big family I don't
know what squeaky gets up to half the
time
and by this point having learned what
you know about FIFA you have no right to
be surprised by the results of Friday's
election with all eyes on FIFA the most
powerful man in football Sepp Blatter
has won a fifth term as president of
that organization come on he presided
over the worst Fiasco in their history
it's like a Sony executive green
lighting a sequel in the middle of
watching Aloha
this this is absolutely terrible and I
need to make sure there's more of it
we'll call it Aloha to this time we mean
the other meaning butters Blatter's
re-election was absolutely a foregone
conclusion
everyone knew this was coming and I can
explain why all 209 members in FIFA get
a single vote for president and a lot of
those smaller members have a financial
interest in keeping things exactly as
they are all share equally the profits
from the World Cup regardless of size or
soccer prowess Liechtenstein kate's as
much money as Germany and Dora gets as
much money as Spain and Monster
advocates as much money as United States
that's right the u.s. gets the same
share as monserrate which eh isn't even
a country and B has a population of less
than six thousand so America a country
with a population of 320 million gets
just as much as an island with a
headcount matching that of a slightly
overbooked Caribbean cruise and that's
why under FIFA system leadership never
changes their elections are such a joke
that four years ago Blatter ran
unopposed this was the actual ballot
paper from that year and they should at
least have added a second box so that
your options work vote Blatter or go
yourself
and the problem is all the arrests in
the world are gonna change nothing as
long as Blatter is still there because
to truly kill a snake you must cut off
its head or in this case its but
but if America keeps driving this
investigation this is important if
America keeps driving this investigation
and actually find something to indict
him I don't think you understand how
much that would mean to everyone on
earth the whole world's opinion of
America would change overnight let me
put this in terms you might understand
if the Dutch somehow found a reason to
extradite and lock up Donald Trump
you would think holy the Dutch are
awesome the judge remote water country
that is what is on the table for you
America and if you won't do it
the last hope to get rid of him is in
the hands of the only group even more
powerful than world governments right
now he's being back because the money's
still flowing in the second Nike says
goodbye or the second visa says goodbye
or adidas or coca-cola or Budweiser I
guarantee you people not the heads of
people will not have the support they
currently enjoy exactly barring an
indictment the only people with the
power to get rid of Sepp Blatter are
FIFA's sponsors these companies and I
would like to make a plea to them
tonight
please make Sepp Blatter go away I will
do anything adidas I'll wear one of your
ugly shoes one of these shoes that make
me look like
Greek god of aspiring DJs McDonald's I
will take a bite out of every item on
your dollar menu which tastes like
normal foods that was cursed by
vindictive wizard and I will even make
the ultimate sacrifice Budweiser
if you pull your support and help get
rid of Blatter I will put my mouth where
my mouth is and I will personally drink
one of your disgusting items I'm serious
it can be a Bud Light
I will even drink a Bud Light line
despite the fact that all the lime in
the world cannot disguise the fact that
this tastes like a puddle beneath a Long
John Silver's dumpster but I will do it
I will drink one maintaining eye contact
with the camera and I will say it was
delicious because if you get rid of the
Swiss demon who has ruined the sport I
love this stuff will taste like
champagne
you